by the way you were in the booth with
Frank Gifford and OJ now were you
friendly with OJ did you know this guy
booth I got to know J yes socially and
we didn't hang out we never hung out
when you see like the fast forward to
you know the car chase follow me no J
you're probably sitting at home this is
closer that's the guy
Oh J no it wasn't crazy because I did
work with OJ for a year and I had not
with me and I never saw him really get
angry or whatever but he had his style
well you're saying in other words you
saw things in him that would indicate a
guy who might go off and do something
stupid well you know what it's I still
try to live by if you don't have
something good to say about somebody try
not to say mistreating women is that the
thing you saw well I may be you know I
spoke of loyalty to a woman or a guy
when we're together and you know I can
be breached of it and there that kind of
drops the credentials a little bit can I
read between the lines that you saw a
married guy hitting on women and maybe
even when you were with a woman maybe
hitting on your woman no never no I
wasn't with him in his company we didn't
hang